[Applause]
in an exciting move this week new york
city announced that all adults are now
eligible to receive a covid booster and
i have a lot of thoughts on this news so
it's time to share them in a segment
called amber's thoughts
it's time for amber's thoughts
i bet she has a lot
it's time for amber's thoughts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that intro song was way too long it's
not done yet
[Music]
is it done almost
[Music]
it's time for amber spots
okay
that intro song is way too long amber it
can maybe be trimmed a little i mean
that would help but i will let you get
to your thoughts on the new covet
booster eligibility
yeah right
uh people getting
the covet booster is
cool
hey amber
did you spend so much time working on
the intro song that you forgot to put
together your thoughts for the segment
yes i got lost in the music
okay well at least the outro song is
going to be epic
whoa
it's
wait that was it i ran out of time
moving on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you